[Music]
my name is Brian Duff and I weed the
Android context team at Google and I'm
really thrilled that you're all here
today and interested to learn more about
how you can use awareness and nearby to
make your applications more contextual
so all of us experience the world around
us with our five senses we see we smell
we hear we touch and we taste and we
react to our world based on what we
experience with those senses and as we
go about our life we encounter many
devices in our home and our place of
work on the bus and on the train these
devices that we have are really amazing
they have a huge array of sensors and
capabilities and just like us they can
sense many things about their world they
have a high-resolution camera so they
can see they have an audio system so
they can hear and make sounds
they have GPS so they can know where
they are anywhere on the planet they
have a gyroscope and accelerometer and a
compass so they can know how they're
orient in moving in space all of these
capabilities are what makes this a smart
phone and these capabilities can also
make our applications much smarter about
what the user is trying to achieve and
accomplish in our applications however
as an application developer sometimes
making sense of all of these signals is
harder than it should be especially
trying to get a more deeper and nuanced
understanding of what the user is doing
so our mission on the context team is to
try to make the takeaway as much of this
complexity as we can and to make it as
easy as you easy for you as possible to
understand the context of the user and
also to detect and communicate between
devices that are around you last year at
Google i/o we announced the awareness
API so awareness provides two powerful
but simple concepts the snapshot API
lets you query and pull contextual
information around devices at any time
and the fence API
setup the conditions that your
application is really interested in and
trigger behavior even when your
application is running in the background
there are many API on Android that you
can use to get this information but the
real power of this of the awareness API
lies in how you can combine various
different signals together to get a
really nuanced understanding of what the
user is doing for example maybe is not
enough just to know that I'm at a
specific place that I'm at the coffee
shop but knowing what it is that I'm
doing there that I'm standing in line
can be really useful in providing a
better experience for my users maybe by
knowing that I'm standing in line my app
can tell me hey instead of waiting
waiting to be served you can just order
your coffee directly from the app and
then I can go sit down
you know hack some Copelan and Android
studio and wait for my coffee to be made
so you can see that sort of combining
these signals together can provide
richer suggestive and predictive
experiences for users one thing that's
hard when you try to build this kind of
experience is doing in a way that says
cognizant of the users battery power and
resources as possible so another great
strength of the awareness API lies in
optimizing system resources as best as
we can to achieve these kinds of things
several years ago we started the nearby
project we had a really simple aim in
mind with nearby which was to allow you
to walk up and use devices in your life
just the same way that you walk up and
interact with people in your life we
were hoping that by building this
technology and by building simple api's
around it we would enable a whole new
generation of proximity enabled
applications so I got to admit something
when we first built this technology it
was actually really really annoying so
we try to use sound to detect the
devices are in the same room as each
other and the early prototypes we built
made this incredibly noisy screeching
sound that totally irritated all the
teams that were sitting around us so we
took a step back and we worked really
hard on the um perfecting this
technology and we added radio technology
as well and we encapsulated all of this
in a really straightforward API called
nearby messages nearby messages allows
you to publish small amounts of
information that the devices around you
and transfer that information via the
cloud
but nearby and awareness have one basic
limitation in order to use them your
application must be installed now that
doesn't really meet the goal of having
people walk up to things and just use
them sometimes the best possible
experience that we can provide to users
is in a site or an application that they
don't even know about let alone have
installed while you're here in Mountain
View if you still have time
I really recommend going to visit the
Computer History Museum on shoreline
they have a wide variety of exhibits
from the early days of computer science
and whenever I go there and I stand in
front of one of those exhibits I really
want to know more about it and of course
I could read the little scientist on
there or I could scan a QR code or I
could do an image search or types of
short URL into my phone but it turns out
the Computer History Museum have a
really great app and in that app there's
a wealth of information about each
exhibit
there's even an audio tour that I can
use to learn more from the experts about
each item so I didn't know about this
app until fairly recently but I really
think it's a great experience if you can
go to the Computer History Museum and
just stand in front of one of those
exhibits and your phone can tell you hey
there's an app available help you to
install it and take you directly to the
place in the app that's relevant for the
thing you're standing next to last year
at Google i/o we introduced nearby
notifications which is the technology
that allows you to attach information
sites and applications to real-world
physical objects using Bluetooth
low-energy beacons so I'm thrilled that
you're all here and you want to make
applications more contextual and I have
three senior engineers from the team
here we're going to talk about best
practices for using these api's and
we're really happy to announce some new
features here at Google i/o so to get
started I'd like to introduce Ryan
Bavetta is going to talk about nearby
notifications thanks
hey my name is Ryan Bavetta I'm a member
of the nearby notifications team like
Brian said we introduced nearby
notifications at i/o last year and it's
been a lot of fun seeing what you guys
have been making with it today I'm going
to go and do an overview of nearby
notifications we'll talk about some of
the features we've announced with it
within the past year and then we'll show
you how you can make your own messages
Brian talked about how we can make these
really compelling experiences that are
based on contextual information but one
of the challenges we have is how do we
start this experience like you said if
the user can skip the line for coffee by
using your app how do we suggest this
app to users without them having to type
the query into the search box nearby
notifications provide the link for
Android users to jumpstart this
interaction and jump straight to the
relevant page within your app into an
app or website depending on your
messages relevance and performance we
made for example light up the nearby
quick settings style display the
notification displayed a message in the
nearby ListView or raised a min or low
priority silent notification so let's
see what this might look like the other
day I was at the conservatory of flowers
in San Francisco they have all these
interesting plants tons of flowers from
all over the world they have these great
signs next to the plants that say the
species name and to find more
information visit this website now you
could take out your phone type in the
URL
ww conservatory of flowers calm gorgs
calm go somewhere else
/ lowlands but wouldn't it be great if
instead you got this link to jump
straight to the content you want this
provides more information about the
plants in that gallery what could be
better than this if it provided
information about the particular plant
you're standing in front of now this
kind of installation is ambitious but
it's possible the finer the context the
richer the experience we can provide
now looking a little later into this
trees lifecycle if we're at the lumber
department of your local home
improvement store and you're trying to
decide between a 1 by 6 or a 2 by 6 or a
cedar plank pine would be really great
if there were an associate nearby we can
provide a link to get the page and
associate for that particular department
that would be cool
another interesting use case we found is
with device setup right now when you buy
a chromecast and plug it in we provide
this notification that allow you to jump
straight into the app to set up the
device if you don't have the the app the
Google home lab it brings you to the
Play Store where you're offered the
opportunity is to install the app and
then continue right into the right part
of the app to continue these setup
another interesting use cases with
instant apps there's a demo right today
in a dome see at the instant app booth
so check that out later where they have
a little birdhouse the birdhouse is bit
a stand-in for an actual home for sale
and it's advertising a link to this the
detail page of the instant app this is
an amazing way to get people access to
the rich content that's deep inside your
app without the user having to actually
install the app so how do all these
scenarios work these you skip easy use
cases rely on the phone detecting a
Bluetooth low-energy beacon nearby
beacons are typically small battery
powered units like this but they could
also be devices acting as beacons
such as the chromecast we talked about
what we do is join the code broadcast
from the beacon to the text that you'd
like to be displayed but we don't want
to show messages to uninterested parties
so targeting is really important over
the past year we've introduced several
ways so that you can target and
fine-tune the context of your message to
only show it to these interested people
we've introduced targeting for time of
day day of week app install state that's
whether your app is installed or not
and we're announcing today distance
targeting which is the distance to the
beacon this alongside good placement of
your beacons helps make sure you're
targeting the right devices bad
interactions like messages that go
ignored or are muted may be reasons that
we may not show your message as a
notification targeting the right users
can sometimes involve stopping the
broadcast for example device setup
messages are great but if your device
hasn't been set up within about 15
minutes the user probably isn't going to
be setting it up any time soon so you
should stop the broadcast let's talk
about the text of your message when
deciding how to phrase your message is
really important to be concise you don't
have a lot of characters available we
found that about 40 is the maximum where
you can ensure that your message is
displayed entirely you should use strong
context in this case we're looking at
for users that are waiting in line to
order and we should make it clear what
will happen when the user taps on the
message in this case the user will view
a menu or place your place in order
contrast this with a message like come
inside our store or sale going on now
these messages are like likely targeted
to uninterested users and the user
doesn't know what will happen when they
tap on the message if you want to test
an attachment make sure to create the
message in debug mode debug mode
messages only show on debug mode devices
oh we're not is that for me
turning on debug mode and on your device
also enabled detailed bug reports which
are really helpful when debugging now
how to add messages the beacons there
are two ways the first way the beacon
can broadcast the URL directly will
automatically pick it pick up the title
in the fav icon from the destination
webpage this is the easiest way to get
started but you won't be able to set
targeting for your message like time of
day or distance to do that you can have
your beacon broadcasting ID and then tie
that ID to the message using the beacon
tools app in the beacon dashboard this
message also allows you to specify an
app intent to be launched both of these
methods allow you to specify a URL that
launches an instant app for details of
the setup process check out our website
again there's a demo today and in the
dome sea so be sure to check that out
now back to Brian thanks Ryan so we've
seen with nearby notifications that you
can enable contextual experiences even
if your application is not installed
once your application is installed there
are a wide variety of contextual
contextual signals that your application
can trigger behavior on and to talk
about this pie impacts ad from the
awareness team is going to go into more
detail about awareness thanks Ryan my
name is Kyle man I'm the technical lead
for awareness API so as you all know
Google offers a rich collection of
contextual signals via various api's
these include things like fused location
provider activity recognition place
detection geofencing nearby messages as
well as a lot of information signals
about the state of the device whether
screen is on or off Wi-Fi scans and so
on so while on the surface these signals
all look like quite different in the way
that they are produced they actually
each one of
them tell you a different piece of the
common story about the the context of
the user where they're at what they're
doing what's around them and so on
so this common theme is rather lost in
the way that developers today without
awareness would have to you know collect
these separate pieces of information
from various api's and put them together
to get the full contextual picture so
last year we introduced awareness API
which offers a common and simple to use
interface to access all these contextual
signals and to seamlessly combine them
in a way that gives you a more powerful
experience
what's more actually awareness does this
in a matter that in a manner that's
power optimized then it manages its own
impact on battery life and data usage so
in a sentence for us awareness API is a
unified sensing platform enabling apps
to be aware of all aspects of users
context while still managing system
health for you we currently offer the
following contextual signals covering
different aspects of users context
including things like where they are
with location and semantics places
what's around them that nearby beacons
temporal context with semantic times
things like whether there's a weekend or
afternoon what they're doing with
activities and interesting device States
like whether headphone is on or not as
well as interesting information about
the ambient conditions whether in
particular as Ryan mentioned awareness
offers access to these signals in to two
ways our fence API gives a call back
style access while our snapshot API
gives the unified polling style axis as
far as awareness fences go you can think
of them as a generalization of geo
fences where you actually get a call
back when a specific condition
on users
overall contextual status met this is
specially powerful because now you can
easily combine you know these various
and disparate signals into a single
custom-made and semantically meaningful
condition that's actually custom-made
for your app and your use case I'll show
the power of this within an example in
the following few slides so suppose
you're writing an app that's interested
in the event that the user is close to a
particular place of interest on a sunny
weekend or holiday morning so just think
for a minute for about all the steps
that you would have to take to make
something like this to happen and here
it is how easy is it to do this with
awareness you can first set up a
wariness time fence for the event that
it is we can similarly one for event
that is holiday and another for event
that this morning all of these by the
way are localized to your current
location you set up another awareness
location fence which is around the place
of interest that you're interested in
once you have these sense objects you
can combine them via awareness sense
language in a very natural way you can
almost read the sentence as this is the
event that it's weekend or holiday and
it's morning and you're near that
particular place of API if you're
interested in more than it for a single
place of interest you can just as easily
extend this API by passing in a
collection of location senses and use
awareness fence thoughts or of all these
things once you have your fences set up
you have to set you have to register it
with awareness and the way you do it is
you create a sense of state request
object you need to pass in a sense key
that identifies the fence you're
interested in and a pending intent
unless you're listening for the trigger
events and you finally register it with
the system at this point you're ready to
receive trigger events your receiver may
look something like this notice that
multiple fences can be registered
against the same pending intent
so you'll have to check that the Penske
that you're receiving trigger events on
is the one that you're interested in and
the current state is the one that you're
reacting to in my example I mentioned
weather so you can access that just as
easily with our snapshot API with a
single line so this gives you the
current weather at the current location
that you're in now I want to emphasize
that what a burn is not only makes doing
all this very simple it actually do does
it in a way that's power and resources
efficient so for example in this
scenario that I just mentioned awareness
will cash and store information about
the local weather conditions as well as
we can then holiday models and you'll
share it across all the apps on your
device that are interested so this will
save on using unnecessary Network calls
another facet of this is that awareness
uses smart evaluation algorithm on the
combined sensors so that contexts that
are costlier to produce are not produced
until they are actually needed so since
last year we actually added some great
new contexts to make the awareness API
even more powerful in particular we've
added some semantic time context
conditions or time funds some of these I
already talked about in the example in
addition to things like parts of day and
weekends and holidays you can actually
now create conditions fences around the
solar x that is sunrise and sunset and I
want to emphasize again that these are
set up at the location that you're in so
awareness takes care of updating the
actual values as as the device moves to
different locations our snapshot API is
just as easy to use it gives you a very
quick access to a fresh sample of all
the signals that you're offering like
places weather beacons days and so on so
since last year that we launched our API
to public many of you have started using
awareness in very creative ways and I
wanted to
spend a couple of minutes to showcase a
couple of interesting use cases work by
our partners the first example is the
card card the assistant that I think in
the last session you actually heard a
little bit about as well so this is an
app that lets the users digitalize their
loyalty and rewards cards and stores
them in a digital wallet format so what
they found was that users often actually
forgets to use their loyalty cards at
the moment of at the shopping point at
the moment that they need to do it so
they've used the combination of
awareness fences awareness on context to
come up with a way to estimate the exact
moment that users need to be accessing
these things and remind them with a
single click access to pull up this
thing another great example is
QuickBooks self-employed and this is an
app that helps users track business
expenses for tax deduction purposes and
they use a combination of awareness
context to accurately estimate the
business-related mileages and as you can
imagine this is a hard problem and you
can only get a good picture by combining
a different set of context at the same
time in the area of digital fashion this
is an app called coded Couture by Ivy
rebel which actually creates a unique
and personalized design based on users
daily life so what they do is that they
use awareness signals like places
weather and activity and try to
translate them in a creative way to
fashion designs for personal life
stresses so with that I'd like to hand
it back to Bryan you can find a lot more
information and examples about our API
is at our developer site and please come
talk to us about how we can make
awareness work better for you
Thanks fine so with awareness you can
really trigger contextual experiences
that take advantage of a bunch of
different signals combine them together
in a way that preserves battery power
one example of a context that we think
is really important is proximity to
other devices since we announce the
nearby messages API a couple of years
ago we've been really impressed by the
things that people have built with it
we've seen applications that allow you
to explore your world
in applications which allow you to
connect with the people closest to you
in your life and share things with them
and we've also seen examples of
second-screen experiences and games
taking advantage of this API to do
really cool things we've also had a lot
of feedback from developers about the
kinds of things that you would like to
see in the future versions of the nearby
API and we've been working really hard
especially over the last year on
bringing some of these things to life
and so I'm really really excited to
introduce Varun Cooper it's going to
talk about how we're taking the next
generation of nearby xapi eyes offline
why why does it take me more than one
click to share an article I'm reading
with my coworker who seated two feet
away from me why does it take more than
one click for me to share the image
search results of poker hand rankings
with my poker group every Friday night
or let's raise the stakes
haha and set a slightly more elaborate
theme I'm in downtown SF we're finding
parking on the street of his offs even
on a good day and then I see this it's
after 5:00 p.m. but it's the 31st
Tuesday of the year but it's a leap year
but the stock market was down today do I
park here or not ah I don't know I look
across the street and I see five
driveways sitting empty
waiting to be parked in I also remember
that I have an app app on my phone that
lets people rent out their driveways
as luck would have it I'm in an area of
SF where I have weak cell signal so as
though as I wait for the long round
trips to the server back and forth back
and forth
I sense a darkness in the force as I
feel the sound of the last chocolate
eclair at my favorite bakery getting
sold out it's too late why why did these
houses not just advertise the
availability and rates of the driveways
so my phone could scan for them and
query all of them and book the one that
makes more sense for me in a completely
offline fashion taking it one step
further if I'm late getting back why
can't these houses then query my car
which will tell again I'm just a block
away so I can avoid being penalized or
towed I'll tell you why because
implementing these features entails
dealing with the vagaries of Bluetooth
and Wi-Fi across the cross-product of a
the range of Android OS versions out
there and B the variety of hardware out
there what these apps back then needed
was a reliable performance proximity
platform that abstracts away all this
complexity and leaves them free so they
can focus on just adding the features
that matter to their users now at this
point I think we all know where I'm
heading and there can be only one
thought racing through all your minds
this guy has got one rock and ooh well
that is kind of you to say and veritably
true allow me to be a cautionary tale
this boys and girls is what happens when
you spend a year working on building
exactly this kind of platform the radios
have commanded their sacrifice in the
form of my hair and my tears so many
girls okay
now that we've established the big bat
of our story it's time for our heroine
to come riding in to save the day
near our connections is the next step in
the evolution of Google's nearby API an
EPA that started with their way messages
as its v1 offering but which also
quickly limited its own reach by a
requiring a connection to the Internet
and be providing a programming model
that is proven to be clunky in all but
the most simple of cross device
interactions UNIX doesn't provide a pub
sub API as its lowest level abstraction
over the network it provides sockets and
now so does nearby in a nutshell nearby
connections enables the advertising and
discovery of nearby devices as well as
high-bandwidth low-latency encrypted
data transfers between these devices in
a fully offline b2b manner it achieves
this by using a combination of classic
Bluetooth ble and Wi-Fi hotspots
leverage and it leverages the strengths
of each while circumventing their
respective weaknesses
for instance Bluetooth has low
connection latency but also provide low
bandwidth Wi-Fi hotspots have slightly
higher connection agency but also
provide much higher bandwidth so what we
do is we connect over Bluetooth and
start transferring data instantly but in
the background we also bring up a Wi-Fi
hotspot and when that's ready we seen
the sleep transfer your connection from
bluetooth to Wi-Fi with absolutely no
work required by the app developer with
that let's look at the flow of the key
primitives of the API an advertiser
calls out advertising and sometime later
or discovery calls start discovery soon
enough the discovery is alerted to the
advertisers presence by means of the on
endpoint phone call back if the discover
is interested they can call the quest
connection this is the end of the
asymmetric part of the API and from here
on everything is completely symmetric
both sides get an on connection
initiated callback that gives them an
authentication token they can use to
verify that they are indeed talking to
each other upon outer band verification
they can both either call accept or
reject connection and when each side
gets the others response we invoke the
on connection result callback at this
point the connection is either
established or it's not from here either
side can send perros by calling the same
payload method this leads to the other
side getting the on payload receive
callback followed by both side getting a
series of on pay load transfer update
callbacks up till the transfer reaches a
final state of successful failure
finally either side can disconnect at
any time and that leads to the other
side getting the on the static callback
aside from that there's a couple more
concepts in the API we support three
kinds of payloads bytes
these are byte arrays of up to 32 K and
they typically use for sending metadata
or control messages files these
represent files with the device of
storage and we make sure that we
transfer from the application to the
network interface with a minimal amount
of copying across process boundaries and
streams this is good for when you need
to generate data on this line you do not
know this final size upfront as is the
case with recorded audio video as I
mentioned earlier we use multiple radio
techniques to advertise discover and
establish connections and the
combinations of interactions of these
techniques are codified in our
strategies strategies are named for how
far they'll cast their net to try and
find a nearby device and what kind of
connection topology they will enable and
right now we have two of them we will be
star and p2p cluster as the names might
suggest we we saw make sense for when
you want to enforce a star network with
a 1 to n connection topology and PB
cluster makes sense when you want to law
for slightly looser n to n connection to
policies for example a classroom app
where the teacher wants to host a
for all the students that would probably
be best modeled over P to be star with
the teacher as the one advertiser
and the students has n discoverers and
the same classroom app could have a mode
that allows students who breakout into
ephemeral project groups this mode where
where students want to drift in and out
of multiple groups would be best served
with p2p cluster now let's see how all
this can be put together in an
undoubtedly harmless mock application in
a world where the machines have not yet
taken over and you feel compelled to
write a fun little app to make a
collection of drone cells assimilate but
Varun
I hear a voice ring out in concern why
would I want to do that that's what the
machines to know and for Humanity to
eventually find out for now let's just
let this slide
so as I was saying in that world since
we want every drone to see every other
drone nearby we'll make both of them it
will make every drone advertise and
discover at the same time because we
want them to exchange some small
controller information before making any
larger decisions like what to do with
these puny humans will make them
instantly connect upon discovery of
another advertiser and will have both
sides or to accept the connection like
so once once they are connected that
short control message we spoke about
could be modeled as a bytes payload in
our case we will let say perform a quick
leader election algorithm words we will
surely live to rue and finally the
leader can send the stream payload back
to the follower that allows sending
constantly changing updates about its
current location so they can move in
lockstep with military positions what
could possibly go wrong
now that was the simple base case of two
drones applying mathematical induction
and generalizing 2n is left as an
exercise for the reader but by an
your end result should look something
like this at this point
brian has insisted that I assure all of
you that absolutely do not have an army
of pre-programmed drone sitting in my
garage armed and ready to take flight at
my slightest whim so move along folks
nothing to see here while we wait for
the day that I've been Evelyn robot
overlords gray cells with their cold
metallic probes we have some slightly
less bone-chilling uses of nearby
connections spotted in the wild The
Weather Channel is using nearby
connections to build a pretty pretty
darn cool offline mesh to help spread
agent weather updates and warnings
especially in the wake of natural
disasters then anywhere is a South
Korean app that allows sharing files
intelligently in the most efficient
manner possible regardless of whether
you're online or not and they are using
nearby connections for that offline
modality pocket cast has has been a
great partner for new expo nearby
messages and they now want to enable
people sharing and discovering podcasts
in a completely offline manner for
example when you're rocking an aircraft
and are looking to crowdsource your
options for entertainment game insight
is a leading game developer and they
using nearby connections will not only
find nearby players but also to run
their games completely offline again
being stuck in the inside of an aircraft
comes to mind hot star is in the
fastest-growing streaming network and
they're using nearby connections to
allow offline sharing of downloaded
movies and TV shows so you don't need to
have access to the Internet you need to
meet your new access to a friend who
does and finally Android TV is about to
launch a new remote control app where
they use nearby connections to not only
set up your new Android TV and configure
it to be on your on your Wi-Fi network
but also to serve interactive second
stream content in the stream in fashion
oh and before I go there is one more
thing that a PNP PN Park idea I spoke
word back that whichever one of you out
out here makes your billions by bringing
that to life please at least send me a
postcard from your private island so
I'll know that this was was not in vain
and this happens for a good cause
thank you thanks Pirin I'm really
nervous about these killer robots but
I'm sure it's all going to be okay
so the nearby connections API is going
to be available really in a couple of
weeks in a new version of Google Play
services and we're really excited to see
what you're all going to build with that
please keep giving us feedback about the
kinds of things you'd like us to do with
nearby we're really excited by your use
cases and we want to make the API better
there's a wealth of information on our
developer site about all of our API is
awareness and nearby there's a bunch of
examples of sample apps reference
implementation and please join our
mailing list we'll send you updates when
the api's are available and I just want
to say a big thank you to all of you for
coming here I think we can build really
great apps together and and thanks very
much
[Music]